reality on August 21st what happened in
your judgment we we're not in the area
where the LA weather with alledged
chemical attacked
what happened as it alleged we're not
sure that anything happened at this day
you are not sure that chemical weapons
even though you have seen the videotape
even though you've seen the bodies even
though now our own officials have been
there
I haven't finished our soldiers in
another area were attacked chemically
our soldiers they went to the hospital
as casualties because of chemical
weapons but in the area where they said
the government used chemical weapons we
only had video and we only have pictures
and allegations were not there our
forces were police our institutions
don't exist how can you talk about what
happened if you don't have evidences
we're not like the American
administration we're not social media
administration or government we are the
government that did with reality well
what do we have evidence approved enough
well as you know secretary Kerry has
said there is evidence that they saw
rockets apart from a region controlled
by your forces into a region controlled
by the rebels they have evidence from
satellite photographs of that they have
evidence of a message that was
intercepted about chemical weapons and
and that sumed thereafter there were
other intercepted messages so secretary
Kerry has presented what he loses
conclusive evidence you know he
presented his confidence and he
presented his convictions it's not about
it's not about confidence
it's about evidence the United sorry
the Russians have completely opposite
evidence that the missiles were thrown
from area where the rebels control that
reminds me about what Kerry said about
the big lie that Colin Powell said in
front of the world on satellites about
the WMD in Iran before going to or when
he said this is our evidence actually he
gave a false evidence in this case
carried
didn't even present any evidence he
talked we have evidence and he didn't
present anything
not yet nothing so far with you know not
not single shred of evidence